the longest day of the year is typically
the first day of summer in june but for
caregivers to those with alzheimer's
every day can be the longest day for one
husband and wife living with the
crippling brain disease it's a lesson in
being grateful for every day you have
together
you don't concentrate you don't
concentrate on that
do this one first
okay jana lee richards was diagnosed
with early onset alzheimer's at just 54.
she asked her husband michael to retire
and become her caregiver i just went
into that gear that protective mold and
just
you know in their mind those marriage
vials when you when you know the better
for worse i had to jump on it and then
boom and thankfully he did it's been
seven years and michael says jana lee
today doesn't always recognize her
husband of 31 years i'm not gonna lie
it's stressful every day 24 7
but it's under control
michael creates a new playbook each year
to help navigate the changes in janely's
behavior and he finds comfort in regular
outings together and their home routine
staying busy with the details of her
daily care i would like for her to uh do
puzzles but she doesn't have the
patience
she has distractions
you know so
i left that alone but
her thing is
movies tv kids
she loves dancing she'll dance and try
to twerk or whatever she'd be doing as
michael says he lets her be her that's
something important he's learned through
the alzheimer's association support
groups and other programs
family time with their two grown
children and grandkids helps keep jana
lee engaged and in good spirits she's
not mean
but she can be but only lasts
two or three seconds
because she can be honoring she can be
jana lee back in the day
where she's real like
no
you know i ain't doing it oh yeah she
still has janet elite in her
and i like that i'll be missing it and
watching his wife's memories slipping
away
somehow the long caregiver days for
michael
yes ma'am
that's one of my favorite are you sure
you sure okay you sure still don't seem
to be long enough
michael urges anyone who shows signs of
alzheimer's or dementia to see a
neurologist right away get a diagnosis
as early as possible and involve your
entire family in the care and planning
of your loved one well if you'd like to
sign up and join excuse me the longest
day alzheimer's event we'll have the
link to sign up on our website at
8newsnow.com
it's the day with the most light is the
day we fight that is the first day of
summer every year the alzheimer's
association has chosen that day to
fundraise and bring awareness to
alzheimer's disease and it's a
fundraising event that you can do
absolutely anything you can do it alone
you can get a team you can use your
family your neighbors and whatever it is
you choose however you'd like to raise
money that day but it is the longest day
and
in a lot of people's lives as you've
seen there with the richards every day
can be a long one but boy they sure make
the most of every day and they
enjoy each other yeah he's an amazing
man he really is a beautiful and she's
amazing too oh my gosh yes and